bindi Irwin boyfriend Cheers her on  during Dancing with the Stars  the seventeen-year-old had an extra  reason to smile on Mondays Dancing with  the Stars  her boyfriend Chandler Powell was in the  audience as she danced the quickstep  [Music]  [Applause]  the cute couple pose together backstage  after bindis performance which earned  her a 32 out of 40 on Sunday the  Wildlife Conservation has shared an  adorable snap with her beau gushing in  the caption thank you for always making  me laugh helping me to ice my foot when  it hurts making me tea and hugging me  when I'm tired you're amazing  bindi and Chandler met back in 2013 she  recently opened up to ET about how  smitten she is there is someone special  in my life right now and I'm really  happy with that